many people who travel consider the
journey their reward I've returned to
southern Germany for my second leg of
the Romantic Road
scenic route full of wonderful sights
on this stretch I will set out from
nerdling in and drive all the way to ox
book
and this time I've set myself a pretty
ambitious it January I'll take in a few
old Imperial cities visit an impressive
castle complex hopefully learn how to
fish and I'll end my journey in X book
where I'll try to find out a thing or
two about the legacy of one of the
richest men in history evidence of
history is everywhere on the romantic
road and one of the best places to get a
good overview of that is from the daniel
this tower in nerdling in the landscape
is defined by an enormous crater that
was created 15 million years ago when a
meteor struck the earth that's one thing
that draws visitors to the area a group
of American astronauts for instance they
ate a meal here at one of the city's
most traditional restaurants
the city walls surrounding the old town
of nothing and may not be as old as the
crater but they've still been around a
long time this wall walk has been here
for almost 700 years and is still
completely intact
the exact route of the Romantic Road has
been adjusted in a few sections in
recent years it's been redirected away
from highways and on to quieter
definitely more romantic country roads
oh wow this is exactly the kind of
romantic place I dreamt about as a
little girl
hard work castle it was once the home of
the Ottoman Valentine dynasty alas the
last prince has vacated the premises but
lucky for us it's been beautifully
maintained
next up don't out that 3/4 of the city
was destroyed during World War two but
it's proud citizens wasted no time in
having it rebuild and managed to return
their town to its former glory in 1946
done' votes claim to fame is a
collection of dolls that were made over
the course of the past 100 years I'm a
cicada CUDA doll museum Keita Cuza first
worked as an actress but she got her
started in a toy trade after her
daughter wished for a doll that was more
lifelike the rest as they say is history
today her originals are much
sought-after collector's items my boy
makes Katie coos a doll so special it
had Patrick who's a put the focus on the
child at play and developed a doll to
reflect that the doll is not a model of
what the child is suppose become it's
not a grown woman a mother cooking at
the stove in the family home the doll
was a reflection of what the child was
namely a child the childís doll was a
toy for the kids to play with he came to
his feet like fatique Hinda
don't avert is said to have been founded
by two fishermen at the point where the
Vernon's River meets the Danube place to
catch predatory fishes near the mouth of
the river I've never been fishing but if
there were ever a good place to give it
a shot seems like this might be it and
petah clear is going to show me how it's
done
thank you what kind of fish are
indigenous to these parts the most
common fish is the pike perch it's the
best fish for eating then there's the
pike it's a predator there have also
been more and more catfish around here
recently you can really switch off and
forget everything around you including
of course time sounds great let's give
it a shot
that you'd be so proud of me so okay
let's go down to the water hold on to
something
take your time is it slippery yeah it is
and a bit muddy too
the whole secret is to keep your wrists
stiff I take it back into the one
o'clock position and don't let it flop
down too much when you cast take it back
like this just try it slowly well this
is going great
sometimes people have beginner's luck
and catch a huge finish the first time
they try it I've seen everything
yeah this is the kind of fish we hope to
catch but no such luck what went wrong
in Sydney well the conditions were less
than perfect the water level is too low
and it's not the right time of day we
wanted to catch a so called Danube
salmon but the conditions weren't quite
right we'll try again some other time
make for the picture
my last stop on this stretch of the
Romantic Road is x-book the city is one
of the highlights of this turistic route
in addition to the beautiful
architecture elq's book has something
truly unique to offer the Fuger eye one
of the world's oldest welfare
institutions at the beginning of the
16th century Jakob fuga probably the
world's wealthiest man at the time
founded a housing project for people in
need those who found themselves hard up
or impoverished through no fault of
their own could find a roof over their
heads in exchange for a symbolic payment
of one Rhenish Guilder
and even today around 150 people call
this place home thanks to the
benevolence of Jakob Fugger subbing in
areas a member of staff kindly gave me a
tour and told me more about the
foundation
enough who's eligible to live here in
accordance with Jakob [ __ ] wishes you
have to be an Alex Berger Catholic and
needy the thing I'm sure a lot of people
qualify on all three counts how do you
choose the candidates that's in we're
here at the foundation and Alex Berg
rely on the social welfare
administrators to do the checks we also
write two pupils home parishes to see
whether someone is registered in the
church and we talk to social workers all
seems too easy and too good to be true
what's the catch there's no catch you
shouldn't see it that way but you do
have to be Catholic I've heard they have
to pray three times a day how do you
control that do you do home checks do
they pray in public or is it up to the
individual to do it their own way it's
once woman people are required to say
three different prayers once a day the
Lord's Prayer the Hail Mary and Apostles
Creed it's up to the individuals
themselves to decide where they say them
if people used to go to church but
there's nothing written in stone that
states where prayers are to be said and
the only one who keeps track is God and
somehow that people who move in here pay
symbolic contribution just under 1 euro
how is the complex finance I'm quite
sure that's not enough to keep it going
DAF 1 Conlan's overseen the interests
untied name is john 9:4 not from 88 Euro
cents a year 70 percent of the Fuger
foundation's financing comes from
forestry we own a 3200 hectare forest
and we sell wood 20% comes from the
admission prices paid by tourists and
around 10% from a property we rent out
now I'd like to see what the houses look
like on the inside
give money let's go in the kitchen and
have a look around this is where I do my
cooking this is pretty spacious how many
square meters you have 57 square meters
in total that's plenty for one person
isn't it more than enough notice right
here you can see the old arches
after spending many years in the u.s.
Salona barber returned to her hometown
and was short of money
the fuga guy was there to help her out
and she couldn't be happier about it
another one of oak's books highlights is
the beautiful diamond holes right next
to the foger houses
it's a marvelous Renaissance courtyard
which once served as an exclusive
meeting point for the wives of wealthy
businessmen and even today it's still
something of an insider's tip
the romantic road is over 400 kilometers
long and stretches from votes book all
the way to the app so there's still a
lot more to discover on the next leg of
the scenic route we will take in one of
Germany's most popular tourist
attractions the fairytale castle of
neuschwanstein so do make sure to join
me for that till then